this is the aftermath of another attack
on Pakistani Security forces the wounded
are rushed to hospital they include
civilians Islamabad says the attackers
are from the tarika Taliban Pakistan or
the TTP and come from across the border
in Afghanistan
and it blames the Taliban for not living
up to its promises it made to ensure its
territory would not be used for results
on other nations
Pakistan has unfortunately seen in
recent months a spike in violence and
terrorist attacks most of these attacks
are being
perpetrated by TTP which has sanctuaries
across the border in Afghanistan
Pakistan has already fenced its entire
2600 kilometer western frontier to
prevent infiltration from Afghanistan it
has caused hundreds of millions of
dollars and not achieved its purpose
Pakistan is facing a new intensified
wave of attacks from Afghan soil killing
hundreds of its Security Forces
Personnel but the Taliban leadership
across this 2 600 kilometer Long Forest
border appears to be unwilling or
incapable of addressing Pakistan's
concerns
the attack on Pakistani security posts
in chitral
by the TTP has claimed several lives an
operation against it by the security
forces are underway
as reinforcements are sent in local
people also offered to help
the former security official and blames
government policy for the new state of
violence
the government of Pakistan
negotiated
this provided an opportunity to tarike
Taliban Pakistan
to regroup
reorganize recruit
and crossover to Pakistan
Taliban say it's not to blame for the
surge in violence
TCP has no hideouts inside Afghanistan
despite that Pakistan accuses Afghan
soil of being used by the Tariq Taliban
Pakistan's enemies are within their own
country for which we are not responsible
we do not allow them to operate from our
soil
Pakistan expects the Afghan authorities
to act against the fighters operating
from across the border and it warns any
failure to act could worsen relations
between the two countries
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera